yeah there's a double standard with like
uh women in hip-hop where it's like no
matter what you do like people are
always gonna assume the not necessarily
the worst but [ __ ] I told you earlier I
was like I forgot he told me that you
and Kodak had a song coming out because
you were supposed to come up here like a
month ago or something and he was like
well we're waiting for this Kodak Raider
to get cleared but then I just saw the
video that you posted a Kodak braiding
your hair and I was like damn kodak's
dating Armani Caesar Kodak is just a
certified lover boy so I think he just
give off that like flirty energy yeah
shout out to him he's I mean he bought a
Shannon Brown's ex-wife uh Monique purse
the other night yeah Monica but he's
sweet like that though like he's the
type that you don't even have to be with
him like he just did he buy you anything
he did the record I was happy enough
with that [ __ ]
no I wasn't free but you know it's
discounted he just looked out you know
what I'm saying for for a person that's
still underground and stuff like that
like and I slid in his DM I was like yo
like because I was listening to you know
the album and I'm like damn like we need
a couple more features just to wrap this
up and I um I was just like well [ __ ] it
yeah let's just see what happens he hit
me right back and I sent the song I'm
like let me know if you [ __ ] with it
he sent me right back he was just like
I'm about to stretch the beat I'm gonna
send it back to you he sent them in like
three hours oh [ __ ] yup and then the
next maybe like a week or two later
pulled up and did the video yo that
doesn't happen usually never like
especially an artist that big like
usually you're like waiting like two
months or something you're like yo did
he forget [ __ ] that ain't even as big
as that right like Conway
don't do Conway Conway did take way
longer to do that I know he did Conway
takes way longer than everybody
I love him as well but like even with
all the backlash that Kodak was getting
at the time you know I was kind of like
leery like you know not so much Larry
because I know that I'm me and I know
how I carry myself so oh was this during
the uh like when there was they were
trying to there was somebody
were they trying to like uh paint him
out to be the
yeah
I don't know who it was but it was Lotto
yeah I think it was something like that
but I was gonna say like is it like are
you starting to
you gotta I feel like as a as a woman in
hip-hop you have to have thick skin and
you gotta kind of like understand like
whether it's right or wrong people are
going to look at you a certain way up
until they hear your music I mean I
think
me coming down to North Carolina and not
knowing nobody and having to establish
myself with the DJs with even my studio
sessions like locking that [ __ ] down for
10 hours at a time
but it's like how you carry yourself
like I'm you know I don't move like how
everybody moves so people know not to
play with me even if it's like at first
you think oh [ __ ] like she fired I'm
gonna shoot my shot it's like once you
see that I'm really about business then
you ain't gonna play with me like that
was uh when did you how long ago did you
guys shoot the video uh we shot it made
of America weekend in Philly when was
that that was like that was like in
September September 1st I want to say
yeah yeah I remember that weekend yeah
that's dope so it was all in Philly yeah
that's what's up